oliva je crois comme à calais ils
croient comme gilbert est et sort des
emmerdes y est c'est parti c'est pour
johnny c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est catherine hors jeu ou
le retour du rebelle à côté de chez soi
a cappella pour le téléspectateur pour
serrer les poings proto ni dans celle
anniversaire et qu'il n'a pas d'âge
je vous promets aux pieds je porterai
des babouches
je vous promets l'avoir toujours la peau
très douce je vous promets de plus trop
de nadine amouk des lancers des coups de
gueule et les perruques de ouf je te
promets bébé tu voudrais te promet aussi
que je veux être augmentée ça c'est vrai
bon coeur oliva j'y crois comme à calais
ils croient comme gilbert l'est et sort
des emmerdes y est j'y crois qu'obama
pour mon petit abricots et sétoise
promet une année différente et nouvelle
j'ai tant besoin d'y croire au camp
merci à vous merci à johnny mercer
[Applaudissements]
johnny norman en fait ce qu'on pouvait
venir voir puisque le premier à trois
points gagne le jeu venait alors venez
jolie attention question le dentiste
d'enora mais deux jours pour lui soigner
une dent un non mais ça va les gars les
vannes
combien de temps va-t-il mettre pour lui
soigner ses 134 dont way 268 bah bravo
209 en prison kader adore la merguez
sachant qu'il lui en faut vite par jour
combien ont-ils en une semaine kader 56
c'est lui qui adhèrent
pour bien illustrer une clio
j'adorais la répartie clio pas comment
dire est toujours vivante jemma lowe du
bol
attention pour lustrer une clio il faut
on voit passer trois coup de polish par
mois
combien de coups francs at il passé en
deux ans pour avoir une clio baer
brillante cvo 36 36
et non vous dites quoi ta ta ta ta ta
fiche à marc batta par la nappe qui
m'ont dit que c'était 72 que c'était sur
deux en habitation jalil dit dernière
est à sion question jean michel passe
ses vacances à montcuq sachant que mon
cul un diamètre de 5 km et que
jean-michel va à la vitesse de 10 km
heure combien de temps jean michel
va-t-il mettre pour faire le tour de mon
cul 50 kg non combien de temps si vous
pouviez m'a bien par les anomalies ça
m'arrange étaient trente minutes 10 km
en 1h 5 km mais la culture générale
s'est annoncé que des maths c'est que
des maths et bah c'est comme ça sachant
que lorsque tu as ta isabelle raconte
une anecdote la terre a le temps de
faire deux tours sur elle même
combien d'anecdotes peut être racontée
en huit jours mais le 16
non alors vous êtes complètement l'a4
maire de lille dit rose et de dire une
connerie mais aussi de confiance à
chaque émission jean lui balance en
moyenne 50 vacheries sur ses camarades
combien d'émissions jean-luc devra faire
pour balancer mille vacheries 500
n'apporte pas la cave en question
annonce américaine d'abord et 920 va eh
bien je n'ai pas de sens attendez cc
bout mais non sévère à bavans
/ 50 étant donné que je n'ai plus de
questions cian roumanoff qui gagnent pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]